but I heard there was a Fahrenheit 451
movie starring Michael Shannon and
Michael B Jordan I was really excited
then I guess it came out on HBO this
past week I had no idea almost like they
were trying to hide it I was like why
would you try to hide oh I see
[Music]
Fahrenheit 451 or 451 or 450 one so
Fahrenheit 451 is a movie adaptation of
the novel in which Michael B Jordan
plays Montague he is a fireman but
firemen don't actually put out fires in
this story no they actually start fires
they find literature they find art they
find books they put them in piles they
burn them if you're caught with any of
that stuff they erase your identity and
you essentially become no one which
means you don't have to pay taxes I mean
so Michael Shannon plays Montague
Superior Montague meet Sophia patellas
character and essentially after that
he's like maybe what we're doing isn't
so good and it's that story it's
essentially equilibrium told again
though equilibrium was this story told
again but what makes me say this movie
is more or less telling equilibrium
story is this movie does something and
that is bring the story into the 21st
century
even this book was written the internet
was not a thing and they could have
easily told this story in an alternate
world where as I read the Internet never
really happened they're still burning
books though they do still burn books in
this story the Internet is a thing
social media is a thing even Michael B
Jordan seems to be some sort of rockstar
online he has fans and he's burning
books like yeah the best there is and
full disclosure I haven't read the book
so any gripes I have in this movie that
are the same is the block maybe I'm
critiquing the book also best-case
scenario I'm saying the movie and the
book did the same thing but maybe the
book did it better it had to have if
it's a classic because this is not a
classic nor will it be a classic see the
two main places where this movie fails
is it's world building and character
development world building is important
in a story like this you need to know
how we got here and although there are
little tidbits and scraps that are
thrown at you you don't really know the
path I get that you're not really
supposed to knows a path you just have
to know that they ended up here the path
of history has been altered if not wiped
out two people living in this world it
was supposed to make you feel like they
feel it really is the integration of the
Internet and social media into this
dystopian world that was written to have
none of that see when the film does that
increase variables of complication you
introduce one new thing one new concept
into your story it makes way for many
possibilities so in an already
established complex world you introduce
the internet now people have a hundred
questions about how that works is there
someone on a cloud server who can just
take information there's one scene where
there's an upload happening they have to
smash this computer so obviously uploads
happen is there a cloud server connected
to the
how was information so controlled with
the internet better they do illustrate
that the Internet is a more refined
version of what was once called the
Internet but in the world where you see
these people trying to hold on to
culture uploading files essentially it
still works the same how is burning
books gonna really get the job done and
if a movie doesn't properly set all that
up and make all of it work audience is
forced to take leaps they shouldn't have
to do that if they do have to do that
that is a failure of the movie I feel
like actually doing this story with no
internet you can explain the internet
existed but we eliminated it because it
was problematic that would be fine and
Michael B Jordans character really flips
at the drop of a hat he seems pretty
intense when he's burning books he is
yeah then he's like I'm gonna steal this
book what that's so out of character for
him maybe if you had a character that
wasn't the rock star of the firehouse
maybe if you had a character who was
like I really don't feel like I have a
place here and he was doubting it from
the start I do a neat thing and here
that shows even the people who point
fingers are guilty of the things they
point fingers at people for I like that
in concept but not in execution it
wasn't enough for me to say Michael B
Jordan is going to flip at any moment he
didn't seem like he was that close to
flipping I guess there's a romance with
him in sofia boutella no I didn't buy
that either and it's not the 90s like
I'm doing it for a girl it's not a good
enough excuse not a good enough excuse
for him it's not good enough character
development for her I even do this
really illogical thing where I mean this
is light spoiler issue are you warning
there are these people this group of
people who what they do is each of them
has memorized a book which is pretty
intense to memorize a book it's like any
movie that has that you can make that
leap for one character like Book of Eli
one character could do that and okay
he's an anomaly fine everybody in this
house is doing that that's a little
strange
especially when they have this one kid
who doesn't look any older than 14 he's
memorized over 13,000 books
automatically speaking and I'm
estimating his age here but let's say
he's 14 times 365 gonna omit leap year
for the sake of simple man that's how
many days he's been alive he would have
to read about three books a day once and
then he just hasn't memorized and that's
if he started reading books from the day
he was born like he just pops out he's
like alright get me Count of Monte
Cristo even powders like [ __ ] dude
that's crazy
granted they do make him act autistic
they never say he's autistic so I assume
he's autistic he's either autistic or
has Asperger syndrome but isn't that the
simplest thing in cinema it's like oh we
need someone to have a really good
memory I don't know make him out taster
there are worse cliches in the world
then autistic people have good memories
it's just in the words of Deadpool well
that's just lazy writing there's in the
end Fahrenheit 451 or four or five one
it's an interesting concept it really is
but it's a concept we've now seen a lot
that's the danger of taking source
material and bringing it into the 21st
century essentially any updated story
that has that concept did the same thing
that's just called something different
it's called equilibrium but directing
writing and editing in this movie wasn't
quite so polished just came across as
yes Oh God the characters were flat
light very surface level the best thing
that could happen to this movie is to
make it a season of television it's on
HBO anyway so just make it one season of
HBO television ten episodes long could
have flushed out the world we could have
gotten a trickle of information as to
how we got here could have gotten more
attached to the characters felt more
conflict among the friendships as it
stands this movies really forgettable
it's just weird to see Michael B Jordan
and Michael Shannon in a movie I feels
like it's just straight to TV and it
sucks I will say I'm not gonna remember
this movie in t-minus one day Oh God all
right so Fahrenheit 451 have you seen it
have you read the book what's your
favorite dystopian future favorite could
be scariest whatever it is whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]